you call this America this is not
America okay you don't have a bunch of
people coming up again no this is just
not America that's a great adventure
[Music]
hey uh big congrats to all the awards
that went to everything everywhere all
at once
let's go all right did everyone see the
movie I'm a I'm a very I'm ashamed I'm a
shameful Asian why because I haven't
watched it yet what Joe you see parasite
dude but yeah I did I just saw it this
year but dude okay
I was gonna watch it on the plane here
there's a story behind this and I was
scrolling and I haven't watched Elvis
yet
did you like it I loved it really a lot
of I heard a lot of mixed things about
all this a lot of people were like oh I
didn't really like it it's like too long
I'm gonna hear a lot of mixed things out
not with Balto yeah
except for one but everyone maybe I
thought Suicide Squad everyone hated it
unanimous one the first one the first
one I don't know anyone that said oh
that was the sickest movie no the first
one sucked I liked it you liked it I
liked it the second Suicide Squad was
much better but I kind of liked the
first one I was like what's the big fuss
oh never mind because bad opinions huh
so what about
um
what about data what about
um dude he's the man yeah
Short Round Short Round Short Round yeah
yeah was it he data though
was he data he was I thought he was dead
in The Goonies but he's short he's short
round he data oh okay okay fanny pack
guy yeah afraid that's his name that's
his name in The Goonies oh I was
thinking of Star Trek
Maria the trench coat and the boxing
glove would come out come on dude my
only thing about his speech was so great
by the way oh oh man yeah one I just
have one note what's your gripe so you
know how he's coming out right and he
stands up and they're like [__] Short
Round just one basically right like they
they actually say like he's from short
he's [__] Short Round or whatever
they're like he's data and he is Short
Round they're paying Harrison Ford and
he's like yeah Harrison Ford's like yeah
going crazy would have been great right
because if you remember in in the Temple
of Doom he's like no time for love Dr
Johns so then what if he's like
there is time for love thank you
I think a good good bike drop yeah he
missed opportunity I'm gonna watch it
we're gonna watch it on the way back I'm
gonna watch it I am it you should
definitely watch I think you I think
you'll really like it okay okay Nikki
[__] loved that movie it's her
favorite movie she's seen in a while my
favorite movie it's cool and plus uh it
it is now the most awarded film in
history yeah a24 has been killing it
yeah dude who owns it yeah
I don't know exactly
exactly something's up something's up
with this a24 oh you think it's funny
huh I don't know I know that there was
14 editors on this movie oh yeah they
needed a ton yeah yeah they were all
sharing different files with each other
different Marshall Club was in it yeah
Andy the lay Brothers you guys are great
yeah they're amazing the security guards
in there right those guys were sick yeah
Andy and his brother yeah so um Ryan all
of that aside like all the accolades
aside we everybody knows it's great uh
Ben Shapiro had an interesting thing to
say about it oh what does [__]
oh
you call this America this is not
America okay you don't have a bunch of
people coming up again this is just not
American that's a great adventure
that's disgusting it's revolting
[Laughter]
if you ask me I want a good traditional
dry [__] okay dry is clean it's good
it's religious it's yeah it's marital
[__]
it should be dry
[Laughter]
we're just fans we just watch it all the
time
the funny thing is I do have a daily
wire account to watch [__] [__] on
there so it's so I don't know but I love
the way he talks it's just hilarious oh
yeah it's [__] so what do you say
he's great he's like the most autistic
dude on the planet
no [__] human emotion he said um I
have gay friends but I'll never go to
their marriage I'll never do it against
my religion I'll never do it it's not a
big deal
why would you go why would you go
support something that you don't
religiously believe in the fact that
it's two people it's like oh man that's
the bed Shapiro sign forget the uh Matt
Walsh guy's like why would you want to
get married to a man you can't provide
children they can't do anything with
anything you just put a dick in your
mouth I guess
that guy's on The Daily wire too dude
did you see him against Joe Rogan is
hilarious it's so hilarious Joe Rogan
was just asking questions just questions
annihilated the cat that's not good no
not good that's not good it's not good
sound argument if you're getting
annihilated by question
things to ask those yeah questions so
it's just
I love seeing any of these people that
have compilation clips of them dunking
on college students I like when they're
talking to somebody that's equal who's
not in a college student
like then you can see the real thing or
college I do wish that there was
something on the screen while he's
talking to a college student that said
how much the college student paid to
[__] learn from this company and what
their degree is yeah I would love that
you never see like engineering degrees
up there dude they're too busy [__]
sweating they're sweating about midterms
tomorrow or some [__] so it's like some
random degree that you never even heard
of geothermal Studies major
everyone from the uh Communications
political science
I mean it looked more like it was
liberal arts liberal arts okay like we
didn't figure out how that works already
guys
you want to know what he said yes yes
what do you say what do you say about it
wait one more before I tell you you say
yeah what do you guys think he said oh
yeah yeah could you guys would I what do
I think he said what would you say about
everything everywhere all at once like
because you guys know Ben Shapiro I
would say
he would probably make commentary about
the speech rather than the movie the
speech and who won it was not the first
Asian who won the first Asian won the
1980s everyone knows that already
said something like that like a smart
ass [__] like yeah see this is the
welcome gender the leftist agenda is to
make it make everybody think that we
don't celebrate minorities we always
celebrate maybe we celebrate minorities
way too much I just had a timeline her
history of solving Monarch Visa Abraham
Lincoln was a minority uh
is that spot on
I mean anything with that tone is pretty
small yeah yeah no actually the here's
the interesting part is that his take on
this movie is actually one of the least
political things that I've ever heard
him say like it's not I don't want to
look at it
it's not even
um it's not even what you would expect
like you would think because the first
thing you always think when Benjamin has
something to say about anything is that
he's gonna go and this is an example
another example of how the left is using
their influence yeah in all of our
things including art and Cinema like but
he doesn't he doesn't do that what okay
what if he's a [__] Kung Fu just
Lover he goes I you know what I was
waiting for something in America to have
something like this yeah finally Hong
Kong Cinema American Cinema together
[Laughter]
the interesting thing is that he
actually is looking at it from the point
of view of a person that watches movies
and writes screenplays because he used
to try to write screen please I don't
know if you guys knew that he's a big
movie guy yeah he's big on movies like
does he do movie reviews
I agreed with him on Star on Star Wars
because I thought the new Star Wars
completely sucked dick ass it was
terrible yeah terrible so he says Star
Wars
he goes in five years nobody will watch
everything everywhere all at once the
movie is meh it is over long two hours
19 minutes confused generally bizarre in
fact nobody has watched a single Best
Picture Winner five years later since
2007's No Country for Old Men
I think it's interesting okay aside from
Saints man the last part makes sense
that's true people don't tend to watch
best pictures like over and over because
they're a [__] bummer dude yeah
nobody watching Moonlight like [__]
ever we'll watch that one that movie's
like heavy right like you watch that
movie like it's a great movie but you're
never like I'm gonna watch this again or
parasite that's like somebody who bought
Blue Valentine it's like bro you bought
that [__] movie Why you wanna watch
it again I agree that like movies that
take you to a very heavy place you don't
tend to just watch them over no you use
movies for escapism to to a better
reality than the one you're living now
yep you know how many times I watch Back
to the Future way too many times because
it's good it makes a fun movie it's a
ride it's a ride yeah take me to
Universal Studios you know who's
watching Schindler's List Right Now kids
in school kids who have to nobody's at
home going like pop it
you know who I think is watching it
neo-nazis oh [__]
they're watching the the sad scene oh I
see over and over and over like Chris
Rock watching Will Smith get whipped yep
in terms of the second half of that I
totally agree a lot of a lot of Best
Picture winners we didn't watch again
cool the first part I don't I don't know
the movie is maybe it's objectively not
met
I don't think like the the scale in
which they created this there's a lot of
things to appreciate that I don't
believe but again you know what I think
for this movie too though like I think
most people would say like I think he's
right on the best picture thing that
people don't watch it afterwards but I
think this is an exception to that rule
because it's fun there's so many like
different parts of the movie that's like
entertaining and like it's visually
pleasing too yeah it's so different
where you're like oh I think I would
watch this to be entertained rather than
like to feel like a Schindler's List you
know the comparison let me let me read
you guys some of the Best Picture
winners and tell me if you've watched it
another time okay past the first time
well I don't watch movies more than once
we're gonna we're gonna start we're
gonna start with the most recent we're
gonna move back until we reach no
country of old men which he admits
people do watch again and I admit I do
watch that movie quite a bit Yeah so uh
2020 Nomad land
never would ever see it never seen it me
too what's that I don't know 2019
parasite yeah I loved it yeah did you
watch it more than once nah I watched it
once yeah but it's a rougher it's a
rougher but it's also oh you already
know what's gonna happen right part of
it's the surprise is awesome yeah yeah
yeah true uh number uh 2018 green book
never oh yeah what's that that's I I've
never seen it
I thought you watched it oh yeah yeah I
thought I thought that was Moonlight
that year that's why oh sometimes you
know what it is I think sometimes I see
a trailer and I'm like I've seen this
movie before like it's like that for
that one it was like that it's Remember
the Titans but it was really hinder uh a
movie that you want to watch like
Charlie's Gonna Make It or Break It
really yeah that's true all right that's
why I don't watch trailers I go off
rumors good for you shape of water
oh I remember that the one with the
mermaid I watched it but not more than
once yeah
Best Picture
that's a weird one yeah I mean look cool
dude Abe Sapien from [__] Hellboy in
that movie because remember they he's
the same director he got the Abe Sapien
guy and just [__] made him in his old
woman into a woman all right now we're
back to 2016. Moonlight did you watch it
more than once once 2015 Spotlight did
you watch that at all I watched it once
and that was about the Catholic church
that was that was the most boring movie
ever made really yeah I thought it was
more than two I didn't like it I watched
reading newspaper
I probably it's great movie I'd probably
just how dare it gets bigger well
because it was about the molestation of
kids in the church oh I'd watch that
multiple times
2014 Birdman
I saw that once once I shot once but I
really loved it I did like it yeah I
think I was too young to understand 2013
12 Years a Slave definitely wants to
yeah definitely I don't even think I
could go there and watch it again yeah
it was Heavy uh 2012 Argo
that was really good that was good that
was really good but I already knew the
story so spoiler watched it once yeah
2011 was the artist
the artist oh the silent picture no I'm
out
2010 was The King's Speech dude nobody
wants that one soon
[Laughter]
great
did you watch it part of white history
[__]
that was really rooting for them history
I really hope yeah you take it easy over
there white history all the white people
are like you got one it's a good movie
you guys saw it more than once no just
once all right number okay 2010 or 20 uh
2008 for some reason skips The Hurt
Locker oh yeah honestly I hate that
movie that's white history man really
[__] bro twice but not by choice oh was
whack a wackadoo Affair I liked it yeah
I liked it too I liked it as well I
think it was once the second time was it
was yeah it's very stressful I think
it's a stressful plot it's a stressful
camera guy yeah
remember guys going like this the whole
time whole time
all right I threw up watching that movie
where's the Cloverfield 2008 Slumdog
Millionaire fire great movie I'll watch
it again I would love to watch the game
but I can't get around to it yeah I
don't remember watch it again the
[__] who you know in the little
mirror writes the wrong answer or was it
the right answer
don't spoil
yeah so now we're back to 2007 and
that's No Country for Old Men so uh he
is right for that second part we none of
us could admit to having watched any
single one of those movies a second time
but how many how many of us do watch
movies
I love watching movies multiple times
what's your goal twos
I Scott Pilgrim I watch a lot I watched
a lot of programs because that's a fun
like Court game I watch a lot of Quentin
movies more than one and he barely wins
let's go Boys Back to the Future I've
seen 80 times I'll go to screenings of
that yeah there's some movies that you
can watch over and over again and you
never get tired of it like score sazi
films but he never wins anything I mean
yeah a lot of cult films don't always
think because that's the Wall Street I
watched that a bunch yeah you watch Big
Short a bunch no it's never really on
four years I've watched like 50 times
Warriors the worst I love that come out
and play I need to see that movie I've
never seen it that's a great movie dude
as a fighter I'm surprised I'm jealous
of you guys can you call yourself a
fighter without watching The Warrior how
dare you watch a movie
one of the best soundtracks in cinema is
that [__] movie that's what everyone
says Walter Hill [__] great movie
thank you you're not a real fighter
unless you watch Walter Hill Walter Hill
dude can you look that up what's his
birthday
what's his net worth after taxes
[Music]